and did it feel cooler today compared to
yesterday's 70s well
63 degrees our official high for the day
today please switch up for me guys
appreciate that 49 degrees overnight for
the low 69
is our average so temperatures will be
below or we're below average for the day
today after the 70's yesterday
the record on this day 87 degrees set
way back in 1989. now let's get to some
neighborhoods shall we 61 degrees
for centennial hills summerlin cooler
obviously for you mid 50s right now and
63 for aliante same goes for downtown
and north las vegas
and the east side coming in at 63
degrees 63 also green valley
that seems to be the popular number
right now 59 for rhodes ranch
mountains edge inspirada and also
southern highland 61 for you joining us
from henderson outside of town prepa 58
64 for mesquite 70 even
for laughlin so nice and mild downriver
and laughlin and of course
obviously out there in death valley so
we started off with clouds this morning
you can see them just moving off and
that's that clearing we're seeing
outside
right now didn't get any of those rain
drops because it was still so dry
at the lower levels that anything did
come down again dissipated we talked
about that that's virgo right
that's going to change though tomorrow
as we start to saturate the air a little
more dew points are going to go
up and the chances for showers will
increase across the region all from this
low out here
that is spinning off the coast right now
and providing already rainfall to the
bay area northern california
and the pacific northwest what's our
chances tomorrow we're going up those
chances best on wednesday
thursday slight chances along with
friday your weekend that's out of here
the time window for that really is going
to be
midday and through the afternoon your
best chances for those passing showers
at least for now
one thing we're going to see though that
system starts to make its way inland too
is the temperature drop
so 63 today tomorrow will only be at 56
degrees after 70's yesterday
i want to keep around some of that wind
for tomorrow no wind advisories have
been issued nor to expect any
but we will still keep it breezy for
tomorrow with those gusts possibly
up to 30. so here's your forecast 44
degrees overnight windy and chilly
we'll keep around those gusts possibly
up to 30 or more 56 for tomorrow like we
talked about passing showers
breezy and cooler for your hump day
highs across the valley in the mid 50s
from centennial hills
54 summerlin 53 55 for mountains edge
north las vegas same for you along with
aliante and 54 henderson 58 for green
valley
outside of town don't worry we got you
covered 53 for prompt 58 for mesquite
and 65
for laughlin tomorrow afternoon now here
is your most accurate
extended eight day forecast now remember
those chances of showers
still out there thursday and friday we
hope we'll get some we're also going to
drop the snow levels too so keep that in
mind it'll be chilly
and then look at that you get to your
weekend we'll clear things out a little
bit warm it up
and then breezy again by monday that's
your most accurate weather update
denise our